Today we're going to talk about the Bible's signs of the end times.
Let's start with our "word of the day" — here are two characters.
Which one is the character for "the end"?
I think the Chinese people were really quite wise.
You'll notice the character for "end" is longer on top and shorter at the bottom.
See how it seems to narrow as it goes, like it's coming to a dead end?
The opposite is the character for "not yet" — narrow on top and wider at the bottom.
It opens up wider and wider — suddenly bright and open, a whole new horizon.
These two characters capture the hope of our gathering today.
The hope that your life turns from a dead end into a future —
from the end of the road,
into a bright and glorious future.
I wonder if you've been following the news.
Sometimes there are these terrifying scenes in the news,
and sometimes people describe them as "the end of the world."
For example, this photo here — you can see it's from a few years back.
Back in 2017, there were reports of wildfires,
burning fiercely, with smoke billowing up into the sky.
Or take, for instance, about half a year ago —
the great forest fires in Borneo, Indonesia.
They burned so intensely
that even though it was the middle of the day,
the whole sky had turned red.
Some described it as red as the end of the world.
Or take the recent pandemic —
over in the South Korean city of Daegu,
because of the outbreak, the whole city was almost deserted,
as empty and desolate as if it were doomsday.
Sometimes news reports, whether intentionally or not, end up referencing the Bible.
Here's a news item from just a week ago.
It carried a warning that the world is heading for famine.
And how did they describe it?
They called it a famine of biblical proportions.
That's the phrase — "a famine of biblical proportions."
There was even the birth of a certain calf
that stirred up all these end-of-the-world anxieties.
We'll have a chance to come back to these news stories in a little while.
During the pandemic I once came across this photo.
Whoever put masks on these stone statues certainly meant well.
But it made me think of an eight-character saying:
"the true God creates man; false gods are made by man."
If these stones could actually catch a virus, that would be one thing;
but false gods are made by man,
while the true God is the One who made man.
And since He created man,
and human beings have reason,
the ability to analyze,
this God, of course, has that too.
He's given us plenty of evidence,
so that we can know, rationally, that He is real —
His existence,
and how precious He is.
One of those pieces of evidence is the Bible.
The Bible is full of prophecy.
Someone has actually done the count,
and more than a quarter of the Bible is prophecy.
As the name suggests, prophecy means something that hasn't happened yet
is told beforehand,
and when the time comes,
it really happens just like that.
And so, through prophecy,
we come to know that God is real,
that the One the Bible speaks of is the true God.
At the same time,
He also wants us to be prepared.
To prepare on purpose.
When the sky is full of dark clouds,
and you're heading out,
wouldn't you take an umbrella?
So in the same way, through prophecy God wants us to be ready.
So does the Bible actually say anything about the last days, the end of the age?
Two thousand years ago, when the Lord Jesus was on earth,
there was a time when He was together with His disciples,
and they put a question like this to the Lord Jesus.
What did they ask?
They said, "Tell us, what will be the sign of Your coming, and of the end of the age?"
The Bible really does tell us there is an end of the age.
But I want to emphasize
that this "end of the age" does not mean the end of the world,
with everyone dead.
It's even clearer if you look at the English.
What does it say here?
"The end of the age."
The close of an era.
When the Bible speaks of the end of the age, it means the close of an era, the end of a stage.
And what does that ending involve?
It involves the coming of the Lord Jesus.
It turns out the Lord Jesus will come again,
and He will begin a new era.
The Lord then answered His disciples.
And what did He say?
In response to their question about the signs of the end,
the Lord said this.
He said, "Take heed that no one leads you astray.
For many will come in My name,
even claiming to be the Christ,
and they will deceive many.
And you will hear of wars and rumors of wars.
Nation will rise against nation,
and kingdom against kingdom.
There will be famines and earthquakes in various places.
All these are but the beginning of the birth pains."
But I want you to notice something.
The word for "disaster" in the original is "birth pains."
What does that mean? It's like a woman giving birth.
You'll notice that as she gets close to delivery,
the contractions come more and more frequently,
and more and more intensely.
That is exactly what "birth pains" means.
It means you won't just see these signs;
these signs will grow more and more frequent,
and more and more severe.
A moment ago, did we notice that news item?
In Daegu, South Korea, the city center looked completely deserted.
And why was that?
Because at the time there was a severe outbreak in Daegu,
and that outbreak mainly involved a number of large gatherings.
I think you've heard about it in the news —
the so-called Shincheonji church.
I don't know if you're aware of this,
but its founder claims to be Jesus Christ Himself.
It turns out there are more than twenty people in South Korea who claim to be Jesus Christ,
and a great many people really do listen to them.
In these opening months of 2020, the world situation has been very tense.
Just think of the conflict in the Persian Gulf,
the tension between the United States and Iran,
which even now, in April, still hangs heavy with the clouds of war.
So for some people, their New Year's wish might simply be world peace.
Besides wars, the Bible also mentions
something in particular — commotions.
"Commotions" — what does that word actually mean?
It means not only nation rising against nation, as we said,
and people against people;
"commotions" are a kind of disturbance,
some kind of unrest or upheaval.
For example, France's Yellow Vest protests, which dragged on for years,
or last year's anti-extradition-bill movement in Hong Kong.
You'll notice these kinds of unrest are happening all over the world,
and they're only getting more serious, more intense.
I don't know about this little family of cattle here —
did they ever imagine that one day,
while they were grazing, the ground all around them would suddenly cave in?
This photo is actually from an earthquake in New Zealand,
where the grassland all around just sank down
and collapsed into a pit.
In this chart we can see, over the past hundred years or so,
the pattern of earthquakes.
A magnitude-5-or-above earthquake is no small tremor;
it's a major quake.
And you can see the frequency at which these earthquakes occur
is increasing — getting more and more frequent.
So remember the "birth pains"?
And that's exactly why this outbreak has been
given the name a 'pandemic' —
meaning an outbreak that has spread right
across the entire globe.
You know, the word "pandemic" actually comes from the Greek,
meaning "all people" —
that is, it involves everyone.
Think about it — in the span of just two short months,
already every single country in the world,
the whole globe, has confirmed cases.
So the Bible says
there will be famines and pestilences in many places.
You can see it —
truly, in many places.
There's another feature the Bible mentions about pestilence.
Besides being widespread,
it also speaks of
how many people die, how many are killed.
For example, this verse mentions
those killed by sword, by famine, and by pestilence —
as many as a fourth
of the population.
Have you ever thought about what a quarter actually means?
With 7.7 billion people worldwide,
a quarter means 1.9 billion people dead.
That's to say, China's 1.3 billion plus America's 300-some million
still wouldn't be enough to make up that number.
In this photo you can also see the current pandemic.
You'll notice a whole lot of names.
These infectious diseases all appeared after the year 2000 — that is, within just these twenty years.
Whether it's cholera, swine flu, meningitis, SARS, measles, or Ebola,
and also MERS from the Middle East.
This shatters a common myth.
Some people think that in the 21st century, with medicine so advanced,
we simply wouldn't see plagues like these.
But look — in just twenty short years,
there have been so many plagues and infectious diseases.
And this current pneumonia —
think about it, by March the 19th
nine thousand people had died.
One month later,
this is April the 20th,
it had already jumped from nine thousand to a hundred and seventy thousand.
Quite frightening, really.
In the table below — I checked it yesterday —
by April the 30th, over three million people worldwide had been infected,
with more than 230,000 deaths.
That number, of course, is not small.
But if you compare it to the world's population of 7.7 billion,
those infected are actually only about 0.04%.
What does that mean?
Out of ten thousand people, only four are infected.
As for deaths, only three out of every hundred thousand.
Some people put it this way:
if the pandemic is going to ease,
you'd need herd immunity,
which might mean the virus spreading to sixty or seventy percent of people
before there's any chance of it settling down.
From 0.04% to sixty or seventy percent —
there is actually still a very long road ahead.
I mentioned a moment ago
that the world may well face famine in the days ahead.
Why describe it as "a famine of biblical proportions"?
It's saying that this famine will be severe,
and that it will happen in many places.
In fact, I've read some of the reports —
right now it's already very serious.
What is it?
It's that in many places, the farms and the produce —
because of the pandemic —
have no workers to bring in the harvest.
Some crops are harvested, but there's no one to buy them,
and even once they're gathered,
there's no way to transport them,
because there are no planes,
no shipping.
As a result, a great deal of produce simply has to be dumped.
For instance, America poured away huge amounts of milk;
mainland China culled large numbers of chicks;
and Europe had to destroy a lot of its produce.
You can foresee that, in the near future,
perhaps within the next two or three months,
there could be famine around the world.
On top of that, you may have heard, over these past few months,
about the desert locusts.
This locust outbreak is the worst in seventy years.
It's affected, for example, the situation across Africa —
Somalia, Kenya, Ethiopia —
reaching the Arabian Peninsula,
and the locusts have even flown into Pakistan and Afghanistan.
Some people worry:
will the locusts actually make it to China?
Will they invade China?
If they got into China, that would be a huge problem —
with such an enormous population.
But then some people say,
"Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry —"
because the locusts over in China
wouldn't dare fly around four in a row.
And it's not because of any gathering restrictions —
it's because they'd get flattened and turned into skewers.
Now, there's yet another recent piece of news.
It's about the five countries down the lower Mekong River —
places like Vietnam, Cambodia,
Thailand, and Myanmar.
These are all traditional breadbaskets.
But because the Mekong's
water levels have dropped —
look at those photos —
the riverbed is left completely exposed,
bringing drought to these downstream countries.
But this time,
it's actually not a natural drought.
It's mainly because China built dams up in Yunnan,
to generate hydroelectric power,
and that holds back all the water.
And this actually gets us thinking about a bigger issue.
The fact is, most of the world's rivers today
draw their water from the high mountains,
like the Tibetan Plateau.
And because of global warming,
a great many mountain glaciers are melting.
You can just imagine —
if the water tower itself runs dry,
where will the rivers downstream get their water?
And if there's no water,
then the crops simply can't be irrigated.
So this is a huge, looming
crisis over our food supply.
I don't know if you've been following this news lately.
Scientists were really quite alarmed,
because up over the North Pole, in the northern hemisphere,
a very large ozone hole had opened up.
Ozone actually serves to hold back the sun's ultraviolet rays.
If ultraviolet light reaches the ground,
and strikes a person, it can cause skin cancer and cataracts.
Ultraviolet light also damages crops just the same,
so this, too, ends up affecting the food supply.
But — and this is precious —
this ozone hole healed back up very quickly, within a month.
And the main reason was simply that the weather warmed up.
When I think about it, I really feel God is merciful.
The warming weather let the ozone hole close back up quickly,
and at the same time, because of the warmer weather,
the pandemic in the northern hemisphere showed some signs of easing too.
Do you all remember these two photos from earlier?
It turns out the Bible tells us that on the eve of the Lord's return,
the earth will be greatly shaken, the sun will turn black like sackcloth,
and the full moon will become like blood.
I don't believe there's anything wrong with the sun or the moon themselves;
I believe it's the atmosphere that has been affected.
This same passage goes on to say
that it's not only the sun and the moon —
it also says the stars of heaven will fall to the earth,
like a fig tree shaken by a strong wind,
dropping its unripe figs.
You might be wondering,
what stars, falling?
I don't believe it's talking about Venus or Mars —
if those came crashing down, it would all be over.
Back in 2018,
China's space station,
Tiangong-1, came to the very end of its journey
and fell back down to earth,
burning up from the friction in the atmosphere,
and breaking apart as well.
The photo you see there shows exactly that scene.
It's just like the stars falling from heaven.
Just this past week —
I don't know if you caught this news —
there's a project called Starlink.
Its plan
is to put twelve thousand satellites up into space,
to blanket the whole globe,
so that everyone can use their phone
to get online directly through the satellites.
As of now they've already launched over four hundred satellites.
Now, as you know, if they're too high up they're hard to reach,
so they're kept fairly low —
about 300 kilometers above the ground,
a bit over two hundred miles.
Now, if these satellites were ever to fail —
you see, the biggest danger with a satellite isn't its size,
it's its speed.
These satellites circle the whole earth in just forty-five minutes.
So if something ever went wrong with them,
all the satellites at that same altitude would come sweeping into one another,
setting off a chain reaction.
I don't know if you've ever seen the film Gravity —
that is exactly the problem it's about.
I imagine if they went sweeping across like that,
the whole sky would be full of stars falling from heaven.
Then, for example, there's the birth of that calf we mentioned earlier.
Why was it such a sensation?
Beyond the fact that for two thousand years not a single red heifer had been born,
the main reason really has to do with the people of Israel.
What they long for more than anything is to rebuild the temple
and to restore the sacrifices.
But if they are to rebuild the temple,
where must it be built? It must be built in Jerusalem.
And even once it's built,
they still have to purify the temple and purify the priests before they can offer sacrifices.
And that red heifer is precisely what's used for the purification.
They take the heifer — about two or three years old — and burn it to ashes,
and use its ashes to purify the temple vessels, purify the priests, and restore the sacrifices.
So for two thousand years they could never find a red heifer,
and when a red heifer finally appears,
in the minds of many Jews, the time to rebuild the temple has come.
If you take a look at the news,
America's whole strategy toward Israel has actually shifted lately.
It moved its embassy to Jerusalem.
He's really set on brokering peace in the Middle East.
So have you heard of the "Deal of the Century," meant to bring about peace between Israel and Palestine?
This agreement is certain to come about one day,
though not necessarily led by America.
When it is achieved, and they're able to rebuild the temple
and restore the sacrifices — I would really love to see it.
When they offer up the heifer and burn it to ashes — why does that matter?
Because from where they choose to make the offering,
it also lets us know
where, in their minds, the temple is meant to stand.
So we'll just wait and watch for it.
Now, we know that two points can be joined into a straight line.
And if a great many points
all fall along one straight line,
then we can see
that the direction is a settled one.
When you look at all the signs we've just gone through —
false christs,
wars,
commotions,
earthquakes, famines, and plagues,
the changes in the sun, the moon, and the stars,
the things concerning the people of Israel,
the rebuilding of the temple, and so on —
you'll find that all of it is pointing in one single direction.
And what is it?
It's that the Lord Jesus is coming back.
The Lord Jesus is coming back very soon.
May we be ready to meet the Lord.